is helpless under the rubble on her
children's beds her sofas and tables she
was only able to recover two pots a
cutting board and a toy though
everything is gone the kitchen
everything there is nothing left
cardboard wooden and Tin homes were
ravaged by two landslides that tore
through the community of Rio Seco
Southwest of the capital more than a
thousand homes were flattened and nearly
2 500 people affected
Wilbur says his home was spared it sits
between his neighbor's brick walls
I'm so sad for those who have lost
everything it's nature we can't find it
we never know when it's coming
the effects of cyclone yaku have been
devastating in Peru's North and Central
Coast the capital Lima is on state of
Red Alert
in this Southwestern District of
cienegia seven landslides happen
simultaneously
120 soldiers delivered water and food to
survivors here
heavy machinery cleared roads the force
of nature only spared the most solid
constructions for years authorities have
urged people not to build their homes
near Riverbanks or Ravines like this one
this is a natural path for landslides
but poor people will likely settle here
again
for now the mayor of siennegea set up
tents to shelter many of the homeless
and distribute food and other donations
in 2017 El Nino caused so much tragedy
but this is much worse only here
landslides in seven Ravines and families
losing all I feel so useless the
disaster zone is being cleared but the
danger remains we have to understand
deep down that people don't want to move
families don't want to go to the
shelters because they don't want to
leave their family homes
for most of these poor peruvians their
homes were all they had and now even
those are gone Mariana Sanchez